hola cómo estás bueno pues esta vez
quiero resolver está integral tengo una
integral definida en la integral
definida de 0 a 1 ok de la siguiente
función x cuadrada ok que multiplica a 2
elevado a la x cúbica ok esto x de x y
esto es lo que quiero resolver y bueno
como siempre te voy a pedir que pases el
vídeo e intentes resolverla por ti mismo
muy bien una vez que ya estoy suponiendo
que pausa este el vídeo es hora de
empezar a trabajar y bueno hay varias
cosas que me vienen luego luego a la
mente la primera que me viene es
nosotros sabemos cómo resolver
integrales y derivadas de en la función
exponencial es decir nosotros sabemos
que la derivada con respecto a x de ea
la x ok
bueno pues sabemos que esto es lo mismo
que a a la x ok o dicho de otra manera
la integral de a a la x de x nosotros
sabemos que esto es lo mismo que a la x
ok más una constante de integración pero
si te das cuenta aquí no tenemos de la
función exponencial tenemos algo que
está elevado a una función de x es decir
tenemos otra base y lo primero que se me
ocurre es que tal vez podemos escribir
esta otra base es decir al 2 visto de
alguna manera para que tú lo puedes
escribir como una función exponencial y
como hacemos eso bueno pues la forma de
escribe
y esto se me ocurre exponer al 2 en
términos de cómo hacemos eso bueno pues
que podemos decir que todos dos es
exactamente igual que el ya que potencia
tenemos que elevar el valor de él para
que nos dé dos bueno pues la potencia la
que tenemos que elevar para que nos dé
el valor de 2 es el logaritmo natural de
2 el logaritmo natural de 2 o dicho otra
manera lo puedes pensar de esta forma
cuando yo elevó en el logaritmo natural
de 2
bueno pues mi respuesta es 2 recuerda
que la función exponencial y la función
logarítmica son funciones inversas y si
a esto mismo yo lo elevó a la x cúbica a
la equis cúbica ok pues voy a elevar al
x cúbica esta parte pero también esta
parte ok estas dos cosas son iguales y
entonces cuánto es el elevado al lugar y
no natural de 2 elevado a la x cúbica
bueno pues esto es exactamente lo mismo
que tener en
elevado a la equis ubican ok antes de
ponerlo con este color a la x cúbica que
multiplica al logaritmo natural de 2 al
logaritmo natural de 2 esto por las
leyes de los exponentes
y es que date cuenta que estudia se
empieza a ver bastante interesante esto
es muy interesante porque si ahora en
lugar de 2x cúbica pongo en elevado a la
x cúbica por el logaritmo natural de 2
ya esto empieza a tomar forma
ok pues vamos a reemplazarlo y para esto
primero déjenme fijarme un poco en la
integral indefinida y después calculamos
sus límites de integración así que
pensemos primero en esta integral
indefinida ok de x cuadrada a 2 elevado
a la x cúbica ok de x y bueno si
nosotros reemplazamos el 2 por esto que
tenemos aquí esto me va a quedar
exactamente lo mismo que la integral lo
voy a poner como por aquí
es cuadrada ok y en lugar de 2 elevado a
la equis cúbica voy a poner esto que
tengo aquí porque llegamos a que es lo
mismo
ok así que déjame atraparlo lo voy a
copiar lo voy a pegar ok y déjame
ponerlo justo acá lado es más déjeme
hacerle un poco más pequeño y lo voy a
poner justo acá al lado de lujo ahora si
a esto le ponemos al final un de equis
ya tenemos la misma integral d
y bueno seguramente tú me vas a decir es
que está integral y está integral
parecen igual de complicadas pero tal
vez haya forma de resolver más fácil
esta integral que esta integral porque
si nosotros pensamos en esto y
observamos fijamente lo que tenemos
adentro de la integral podemos ver que
tal vez podamos utilizar la sustitución
1 es decir que si yo me fijo en esta
parte que tengo aquí arriba ok ya esto
lo llamo un bueno pues date cuenta que
su derivada va a ser a 3 veces x
cuadrada por el logaritmo natural de 2
lo cual es una constante por x cuadrada
y curiosamente aquí tenemos a x cuadrada
por lo tanto aunque te parece si ahora
llamo a esta parte de acá arriba
1 y que me va a quedar si digo 1 es
igual a x cúbica ok por el logaritmo
natural de 2 por el logaritmo natural de
pues quien es de uno de uno es lo mismo
que la derivada de esto que tengo aquí
lo cual es tres veces x cuadrada ok por
el logaritmo natural de 2 x de x ok lo
único que hice fue bajar el exponente y
darme cuenta que el logaritmo natural de
2 es una constante por lo tanto la puedo
poner aquí y no pasa nada y bueno esto
es exactamente lo mismo si nosotros lo
escribimos la siguiente manera que x
cuadrada ok que multiplica a tres veces
el logaritmo natural de 2 ok de equis y
lo estoy escribiendo de esta manera
porque ahora date cuenta que esta parte
que tengo aquí a esto que tengo aquí lo
puedo escribir como un único logaritmo
es que esto es exactamente igual
ok déjame ponerlo así esto es igual que
x cuadrada ok que multiplica a logaritmo
natural de 2 elevado al
recuerda que por las propiedades de esos
logaritmos cuando yo tengo algo
multiplicando el logaritmo esto puede
pasar como potencia ok de x de x 10 que
lo estoy viendo de esta manera porque
esto es exactamente lo mismo que tener x
cuadrada que multiplica el logaritmo
natural de 8 ok
x de x y es mucho más fácil verlo así
como una constante que multiplica a x
cuadrada de x y entonces dónde está de
un bueno pues ahora lo podemos poner con
algunos colores fíjate bien nosotros
tenemos de x aquí necesitamos una de x
tenemos x cuadrada ok esta x cuadrada de
aquí y lo único que nos hace falta es el
lugar y no natural de 8 así que
necesitamos esta parte de aquí pero lo
bueno es que es una constante por lo
tanto puedo poner aquí el logaritmo
natural de 8 ok y dividir todo entre el
logaritmo natural de 8 es decir estoy
multiplicando por 1 y bueno es que esto
nos va a servir porque si nosotros
recordamos antes de poner que esto es
exactamente igual recuerda que la anti
derivada de una constante multiplica en
una función esto es exactamente lo mismo
que la constante multiplicando al anti
derivada de esta función o dicho está
manera esto es lo mismo que uno entre el
logaritmo natural de 8 ok esto que
multiplica a la integral ok de el
logaritmo natural de 8 que multiplica a
x cuadrada que multiplica a esta parte
de aquí que multiplica a un elevado a la
x cúbica déjame ponerlo con este color a
la x cúbica ok por el logaritmo natural
de 2 ok d
y bueno es que estoy haciendo todo esto
porque ahora date cuenta de lo siguiente
ahora lo puede escribir todo en términos
de un dicho otra manera date cuenta que
aquí tenemos no nos vayamos a olvidar de
este uno entre el logaritmo natural de 8
ok y de esto que nos va a quedar nos
queda la integral la integral ok y bueno
ahora tengo am y déjame ponerlo con este
mismo color
tengo el logaritmo natural de 8 que
multiplica x cuadrada que multiplicada x
pero esto es lo mismo que de 1 es decir
a de un a de 1 que multiplica a m
elevado a la x cúbica que multiplica al
lugar y tmo natural de 2 pero esto es lo
mismo que es decir el elevado a la 1 y
ya está de lujo porque qué creés esta
integral de aquí es muy fácil de
resolver su anti derivada y de hecho lo
sabemos esto es exactamente lo mismo que
no olvidemos este de x 1 entre el
logaritmo natural de 8 ok
multiplica a la función exponencial a un
elevado a la 1
ok más una constante su anti derivada es
muy sencilla y bueno una constante
porque estamos hablando de una integral
indefinida de lujo porque ya con esto
podemos regresar a la sustitución hacia
atrás es decir esto es exactamente lo
mismo
ok que uno entre el logaritmo natural de
8 ok que multiplica a ha elevado a la
'u' pero nosotros sabemos que uno es x
cúbica por el logaritmo natural de 2
elevado a la x cúbica por el lugar istmo
natural de 2 ok más una constante del
lujo pero ahora si queremos regresar a
nuestro problema original que es justo
este que tenemos aquí tenemos que hacer
los límites de evaluación y para eso
déjenme atrapar esta parte de aquí ok
la voy a poner justo por acá ok vamos a
regresar a nuestro problema original ok
déjenme bajar un poco esta pantalla ok
subamos un poco esta pantalla y bueno
esto va a ser exactamente igual ok que y
recordemos los límites de evaluación
primero tengo am el límite de evaluación
en 1 así que déjame ponerlo con este
color y me va a quedar 1 entre el
logaritmo natural de 8 ok que multiplica
a el elevado a la 1 al cubo 1 al cubo es
lo mismo que uno por el logaritmo
natural de 2
elevado al logaritmo natural de 2 ok ya
esto habrá que quitarle a esto habrá que
quitarle ok la evaluación en 0 en 0 y me
va a quedar 1 entre el logaritmo natural
de 8 ok que multiplica a elevado y bueno
0 por lo que sea es 0 elevado a la cero
y esto es porque las constantes recuerda
que se eliminan y bueno que me queda de
aquí lo que quiero que veas es que
nosotros vimos de este color que 2 es lo
mismo que he elevado al lugar y natural
de 2 por lo tanto de aquí esta parte
simple y sencillamente 2 y m elevado a
la 0 bueno esto es exactamente lo mismo
que uno por lo tanto aquí me queda 1
entonces mi respuesta quién va a ser
esto va a ser exactamente igual que 2
que multiplica a 1 entre el logaritmo
natural de 8 menos una vez que
multiplica a 1 entre el logaritmo
natural de 8 o de otra manera me va a
quedar solamente 11 de ellos uno entre
el logaritmo natural de 8 2 entre el
lugar y la natural de 8 menos 1 entre
logaritmo natural de 8 bueno es
solamente uno entre el logaritmo natural
de 8 y que crees
ya hemos acabado esta es mi respuesta
que tanto buscaba de este problema
original es decir que está integral
definida tiene como respuesta uno entre
el logaritmo natural de 8 nos vemos en
el siguiente vídeo